do we have the phone ready if i'm
calling somebody i got somebody here
that just
wants to make a commitment yes you can
and a
good-sized commitment to make this
happen uh
let me know you can plug in your phone
too if you want
uh let me know if we're don't forget to
plug in the phone it's plugged in just
so you guys know right now it's about
your name hang on once i gotta state my
name give me one second
okay so i'm gonna call them up this is
aaron um
aaron is the number is using robokiller
to screen their calls no problem kai can
you pull up a retcon jim
and i'll try to connect redcon jim is a
big gym here uh aaron this is patrickbet
david
he is the ceo and founder of retcon one
it's not just the gym it's also a
supplement
company that they do extremely well
all our guys here go to their gym and
use their supplements
and aaron is known in the bodybuilding
world that is
himself aaron how are you
aaron can you can you hear us
how you doing buddy how you feeling
good good how are you i'm very good i'm
very good thanks for taking this call i
know you uh
messaged me yesterday and you commented
yesterday and we went back and forth and
i said are you willing to say that on
the
podcast and you agreed so if you don't
mind telling the viewer
what was your reaction when you saw that
do you think it's a good idea and if yes
why
yeah so both me and my wife uh saw it
and she commented me check this out
and uh i think it's a fantastic idea and
uh something needs to happen to save
this country
and i feel like why not you why not
these two guys get together and
and start hashing it out they're two
obviously very well respected
people from each individual party and i
thought it was a great idea and i said
hey man
how can i help can i throw in some money
and make it sweeten up the pot
for getting these guys together and
aaron if you don't mind
if the audience doesn't know you we have
your picture up right now on
the podcast do you mind sharing with
folks what it is you do yourself
what it is you and your wife do sure
well i am the uh
the founder of redcon1 which is the
fastest growing sports supplement
company in the world
we're sold in 90 countries uh worldwide
walmart united states military
um vitamin shop gnc etc so uh
we do that and then we also run the red
colon foundation which gives back to
military families
in need and very patriotic
uh brands me and my wife are both very
patriotic darielle
my wife helps run the foundation and we
try to do things to help give back you
know and we've been very fortunate in
this life to
be able to do that and and uh you know
it was great uh spending time with your
wife and your
son i believe that was on my daughter's
birthday this was what uh
six two months ago i think maybe two and
a half months ago or something like that
whatever may was so two months ago
and uh spend time with the family so go
ahead
dog i wish i would have been uh been
there at the party i didn't even know
i didn't even know until after the fact
and gary also said it was a great party
and aiden my son
uh loves your daughter so very cool
last night my daughter comes and my my
wife sends me videos
and my wife's recording my daughter she
sent me private videos about this guy
she met in school and she says the name
and my daughter starts turning red he
says i met this guy
and we like him and i like him and he
likes me and i come home last night i'm
like so
senna tell me about this guy you met and
i give the guy's name and she starts
turning red and she runs away she don't
want to talk about him anyway she's
already flirting with guys it concerns
me
big time long term but it is what it is
so aaron
you saying that are you comfortable
sharing with the audience how much
you're willing to support this cause if
it were to become a reality
i'm willing to put up half a million
dollars of our money to uh to help make
it happen and i thought
if there are more people out there like
me businessmen who
uh who are patriotic love our country
and think this is a good idea which i
think a lot of people
will i think it uh hopefully i'm the
first person to do this out of many
people
that would be willing to put up money
and help make it happen
well brother i appreciate you for doing
that uh
you know there's nothing like having
other people that love this country as
much as we do and the fact that you're
not just saying it but you're doing it
says a lot about what you and your wife
uh are willing to do to reunite this
country and uh
uh uh definitely appreciate you doing
that and folks if you're listening this
is aaron singerman ceo and founder of
retcon
uh aaron maybe we'll have you on here to
uh to speak about this as this thing
gets uh
deeper and deeper into this possibly
happening
you let me know patrick i'm just down
the road we're we're based in boca not
too far from you
all good i appreciate i definitely will
i'll text you right afterwards
uh that's what patrick i've been trying
to get you to the gym dude i gotta tell
you
no joke i've had by the way for full
disc disclosure
i am not a fan of uh uh protein bars i'm
not a fan of these things are i've had
all of them and i eat it because i'm
forced to eat it or protein drinks i
drink these drinks because i'm forced to
drink them
your stuff tastes amazing and i'm being
dead serious guys
your stuff that you sent tastes amazing
i got 30 employees here 35 employees at
the valuetainment media
i don't know how many of them go to your
gym but that's all they talk about when
they go to you they swear by redcon
and i'm gonna tell you this on camera on
the podcast i'm gonna come stop by your
gym today is what today's thursday
i'm gonna come stop by your gym within
the next 24 hours i'll come to your
place and check out your gym next 24
hours
let me know and i'll be sure to be there
to roll out the red carpet the gym
is a passion project so it's it's for
fun for us and you'll see you'll you'll
get the feeling
brother i'm looking forward to it i am
looking forward to it i'm going to text
you i'm looking forward to we'll go
together
thanks buddy appreciate your everybody
take care bye-bye bye-bye bye-bye
half a million dollars okay first half a
million dollars we got right there so
now it's no longer five million it's
five
five point five million and i got
another one here
uh alfred i am calling you here and by
the way anybody that's listening to this
here's what i'm gonna do
anybody that's listening to this
whatever you decide to donate on super
chat today
a hundred percent of what you give on
super chat today
a hundred percent of it whatever you
give five dollars ten dollars a hundred
dollars a thousand dollars whatever it
is
i'm gonna use a hundred percent of it
and we're going to create a what do you
call a a uh
uh barometer that tracks it and we can
obviously start a gofundme
charity tomorrow yeah we need to create
a thermometer to see how much we're
raising for this and we'll keep a track
of it until it finally becomes a reality
and this thing creates momentum and so
whatever you give on super chat today is
going to go to this and fyi if it
doesn't end up becoming a reality
we will figure out a way to give it away
to a scholarship or a charity and we'll
make that announcement exactly the
dollar amount that we raised
but let me call the next person alfred i
am calling you
next alfred himself runs a uh
let's see if we can get a hold of alfred
alfred if you're listening i am calling
you buddy
i am ready to to make a donation of 400
billion boulevards
um so buck is what you want to do
your call has been forwarded
how much did 400 boulevards did hey pbd
i just picked up my phone
and um i posted this on linkedin and my
socials and i just did a quick check
there
i was checking the stats right now i'm
running
this morning it's just it's on fire and
it's running
25 to 125 to 2 on the likes
dislike people that want to see this
happen that's correct
what's up how you doing buddy good good
how are you
i'm doing very good i'm doing very so
where you are right now it's 7 25
california time alfred uh
uh uh can you tell everybody what
business you're in and what you do
oh man uh 20 21 years when
transportation build a
platform for transportation
how many loads you guys do per month how
many loads you guys do per month how
many branches do you have how many
employees do you have
give us optics or else i'm gonna tell
everybody how big you guys are because i
think people need to know
uh we you know we we pretty much move
approximately a thousand trucks a day
a day uh a day yes somewhere on there
and uh we have about maybe three to four
thousand sales guys around the corner in
the world moving
forward here that three to four thousand
sales guys around the world okay uh top
line revenue shy of half a billion
dollars alfred what do you think about
this idea of getting president trump and
president obama sit together
man when i when i heard it was
unbelievable honestly
i can't even believe you even thought
about that i think obviously
you know you and i being immigrants
coming to this country
understanding the you know the values
and how amazing this country is and
uh definitely want to be part of the
solution no question about it
uh and i i even text you i said
maybe uh the first thing is to getting
the wives together
maybe that might be the first uh
shot getting these two guys together uh
money might be more relevant to them
than them but obviously if we can get
those two big boys together that can
definitely make a lot of [ __ ]
change are you are you willing to
support it are you willing to support
and throw a couple dollars of couple uh
you know dollars towards this project of
course i texted you about that i said
look uh i'll put 100 grand
no question about it if you can get this
done i'm more willing to be
another hundred thousand dollars so now
we're at 5.6 million dollars the numbers
have changed so alfred a hundred
thousand dollars
towards uh this becoming a reality
brother appreciate you
i am uh i miss you and i can't wait when
i'm in la for us to go to rafi's place
together and i know we're talking right
now about figuring something out
yeah for sure man for sure
you got it man you got it take care you
say hello to everybody my man i will bye
bye bye bye bye
so we're at 5.6 million now okay and and
you got the six hundred thousand dollars
and the last four minutes was great okay
just wanna let you know we haven't even
started yet right so we're at five point
six million dollars
it's just a couple of the text messages
that got through the clutter that got to
you
imagine everything else yeah i'll
contribute i get paid this friday so
i'll get with you then tell your boss to
tell you a little bit more you know what
seriously ask for a raise or something
by the way we got a we got a
a bunch of people just all of a sudden
started let me see here myron hyman
twenty dollars myron have another five
dollars he threw twenty five dollars
into a thank you
sirfania twenty bucks jorge lopez 25
uh arsenal fan uh five dollars my small
contribution to getting these two glides
in the same room together we'll
appreciate you everything helps
dnd furniture five dollars uh he says a
thousand dollars but it only says five
dollars so you may want to update that
alex h 20 bucks here's a little one i
appreciate that
supreme sean gave another 20. uh i love
this country and i love this podcast
thank you terson tash go america 25
bucks daryl
hamill make it happen pbd 50 bucks thank
you daryl willy figueroa another 50
kevin fischer 10. just jen 25
make it happen cooper lobo 10 bucks uh
george vin [ __ ] pick 100 i would love to
see that interview happen as well
home of the free 10 bucks from hugo
munoz
it would be very i mean seriously if
this were to ever happen
i mean i think the spirit in america
would go to a whole different level
media would media lose their minds oh
yeah would the folks in media lose their
minds if this were to happen good even
better i think they would lose their
minds if something like this were to
happen so folks again
if you want to dnd furniture just give
another hundred dollars jordan becker
just gave another 50
if some of you are listening and you
want them
you know people that may want to
contribute at a higher number the next
phase right now is asking elon musk to
match 50 million dollars
going after bezos to see if he'd want to
put up 10 million dollars going after
folks like that so
if you've seen the video it's on my
twitter i've pinned it all the way at
the top
if any one of you guys want to go talk
to the
congressman media other billionaires
people you may know people you may
do business with friends family anyone
if you know
anybody to get this in front of we are
barely i announced this yesterday
so you have to know that this campaign's
probably going to go on for some time
now to talk about this
to see how much money whether it's
mckenzie basil's whether it's
uh bezos himself whether it's buffett
whether it's any of these guys like
lindell who are talking to you
there could be another one there right
exactly so if anybody wants to see this
happen
let's go make this a reality and get
these two gentlemen
in there to help them synergize and
unify america
so but if you do want to make a bigger
contribution
message us directly send me a message if
it's more than
if you're willing to match a fifty
thousand dollars a hundred thousand
dollars ten thousand dollars a million
dollars five million dollars
contact us directly i would love to have
you make the announcement
on the podcast with the rest of us here
okay
thoughts six hundred thousand dollars in
a few minutes i can't believe you just
raised a hundred thousand dollars a
minute live on the air
there you go and that's just the
beginning tom i think this shows you the
undercurrent that what
americans want is things to come
together americans want things to come
together
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye